let's bring in seton o'connor who joins
us from the road where well where are
you right now seton
uh what uh so i'm in memphis guess where
i am
you're at graceland
let's go
i like that
yeah man i was actually just walking
through there i just got a little tour
it is so rad it's an awesome place now
what's the coolest thing you saw at
graceland
uh okay i'll give you two things um down
in the basement elvis has uh he's got
sort of the original man cave now that's
the jungle room isn't it
no so the jungle room is a different
room which i just walked through too
which is really rad okay but he's got
this room down in the basement where so
elvis is a huge um football fan right
and he wanted to watch all the games at
one time and since there's only there
was three networks at the time he had
three tvs put into the wall so he could
watch football because he was just like
a rabid football fan um and there's like
an awesome couch and a bar in there and
a fireplace and like mirrors all over
the wall and the ceiling and stuff it's
really cool place
um and you stayed in memphis last night
yeah yeah we stayed in memphis last
night uh and i met this dude who uh
knows robert plant nope
hey yeah and i was like oh my gosh dan
would be dying right now if he was
hearing these stories he was like oh
yeah no that's because i was telling the
story about the peabody yes
yes
that you can figure out how to uh like
how do i go start a conversation with
this dude and the guy that i was talking
to said that robert plant is a huge
sports fan uh and like just super down
to earth superhero like oh yeah he'll
talk your ear off about uh like football
or soccer or whatever and that he comes
down here all the time to memphis
and good restaurant last night in
memphis
uh yeah uh blue city
cafe blue city cafe uh
probably yeah on beale it was probably
the uh
best ribs i've ever had in my entire
life they were phenomenal fell right off
the bone they're unbelievable um and a
lot of people say that they're probably
the best ribs in memphis
what's the plan for you and the french
kid today
planned today we're going to wrap up
here um and then head down to right now
it's not raining which is nice we're
going to try and beat the weather and
head down to houston
oh so wait where you that's a different
route
that is a different route so
i think we're trying to we're going to
try to go
oklahoma city is going to get slammed
with the storm yeah so i think we're
going to go a little further south to
try and stay with either like the rain
or the the less bad side of the storm um
so i think we're going to take a little
bit more of a roundabout route to get to
la it's not the most direct route but it
feels like maybe the smartest room uh
paulie do you have the mileage memphis
to houston of course i do dan i got 568
miles uh today
have you and the french kid had an
argument yet
have we had an argument yet no no it's
uh we've been doing really well actually
there are some some stretches of quiet
for sure which i'm very comfortable
sitting in the quiet and not talking to
the only other person there um
but no we've been doing good i you know
i think today might be the test you know
sort of in the middle where we just did
all that those miles and now we got to
go all the way out there today could be
a good test and i think if we're if
we're going through houston that means
we have to go through west texas and i
don't know that there's a lot out in
west texas so that sort of to wrap
things up heading over to phoenix might
be
a little interesting
all right well keep us up to date safe
travels
yeah all right awesome thanks guys
that's seton o'connor with the french
kid in memphis
elvis